d'image à l'intérieur ni d'interview de
salariés dans cette agence intégrée au
groupe thomascook la consigne est claire
les clients eux sont venus dès
l'ouverture remboursement maintien des
voyages ou perte des sommes versées
c'est le flou total ses clients à
réserver un voyage en république
dominicaine
elle est inquiète hier j'ai envoyé un
mot à mes quatre amis qui partent avec
moi en disant t'as vu c'est c'est enfin
c'était vraiment un coup de tonnerre
quoi pour nous c'est ouais ouais
donc je voudrais savoir si avec mes amis
on va pouvoir partir et aussi je vais
perdre mon argent si on va pour me
rembourser 6 voilà je voudrais savoir où
ça en est à chalon sur saône
autre son de cloche lagence de montceau
il avance de chalon ces deux agences
différentes si vous voulez on a la même
enseigne mais ils sont intégrés on est
franchisé nous notre comptabilité à nous
dans cette agence indépendante
thomascook n'était qu'une franchise
les employés ont donc passé la journée à
faire de la pédagogie alors déjà on
rassure les clients parce
qu'effectivement nous sommes
indépendants donc financièrement il n'y
a aucun absolument aucun souci pour nos
clients donc oui bien sûr le client qui
doit partir dans les jours prochains
alors hormis le tour-opérateur jet tours
pour lequel effectivement nous essayons
de trouver des solutions alternatives
le client n'a absolument aucun souci à
ce faire d'un point de vue financier au
moins de 24 heures pour ces agences
franchisées le nom de thomas cook est
devenu un véritable fardeau
tous les logos tous les documents
juridiques ou être modifié dans la
semaine voilà donc c'est arrivé cette
nuit c'est un petit peu tôt encore
malheureusement faut le temps de se
retourner parce qu'on s'y attendait pas
mais ça va être faite très rapidement un
jour prochain si les agences franchisées
vont rapidement rebondir pour les
boutiques intégré au groupe
l'incertitude est totale